was ultimately I made the decision so
that I didn't have any threat of getting
ovarian or breast cancer and letting my
children see what I saw my grandma and
her mom go through so ultimately it was
to protect my family and as I understand
it you carry a faulty gene like Angelina
Jolie carries a faulty gene hers
bracket1 yours as I understand it is the
bracket - how did you discover that you
carried that gene well my dad's mom had
passed away and just before she passed
away they did genetic screening on her
it was just a new thing and they were
discovering that ovarian and breast
cancer was due to a genetic fault
and she came back positiv is Braca - my
dad received an automatic letter as it
his two sisters - say did they want to
be tested that there was a possibility
they carried it he then had the test he
was positive and then I got the letter
how does it feel to get that letter I
remember putting it in a drawer closing
the drawer and pretending it wasn't
about me it was a really weird situation
to have a black-and-white and emotive
and piece of paper that was telling me
that my life could literally change
overnight
and so I I tried not to think about it
for about a year went past and it wasn't
until that I had my daughter face that I
then realized that she had the potential
of having the gene as well and unless I
got tested genetic testing wouldn't be
available for her you have to have a
direct link so even though there was a
risk of her having it she may never know
unless I got tested so that was that was
the real reason why I originally got
tested and when you did get the results
of that test and you discovered that you
did carry this gene what were you told
about the increased chances of you
developing breast and ovarian cancer the
initial moment when I got told
that next hour was to be honest a little
bit of a blur and I have not anticipated
having the gene I think and quite
foolishly
I thought that I would be fine and I
felt fit and healthy and me my husband's
were under the impression there's
nothing wrong with me how could I be you
know I have something so faulty if I
felt fine and obviously that's not the
case at all and you don't need to feel
unwell to carry these and so but that
hour I tried to digest the information
but it wasn't really going in there so I
had to go back a couple of times and see
counselors and until I fully understood
the extent of what the gene meant and
which I suppose ultimately meant I had
up to an 80 85 % risk of breast cancer
and ever Braca - it's a 30 to 40 percent
risk of ovarian cancer and you made the
decision to have a double mastectomy in
2012 you went ahead and had a
hysterectomy last year as well how tough
a decision was it undergo such surgery
as bad you know what the bimbo sex to me
was a lot easier to make a decision on
because I was kind of like they're just
boobs and you know my husband's happy
I'm in a loving relationship and and I
didn't feel that I was that attached to
them anyway and it was just a little bit
of an easier decision and I was like
it's a no brainer to having it give us a
85% risk of breast cancer and was too
great a deal to risk so I had that
pretty much straight away or as soon as
I could
and with the hysterectomy it was a
different story we were not going to
have it that soon we were going away too
little while and what I fell pregnant
with AJ he was obviously amazing and we
kind of took it as a sign to move on
with things we always said that after I
have my second child that we would look
into having the operation second child
came along and it but quicker than we
had anticipated so we just move things
along Angelina Jolie in her article
where she's explained the procedure
she's gone through has said there's more
than one way to do
with any health issue and it is true to
say that a positive test for the bracket
gene doesn't necessarily mean the
surgery that you've undertaken does it
oh I'm not absolutely definitely I mean
it they're two major evasive operations
it was not taken lightly and there was a
lot of recovery and you know I am now in
early menopause
I have very hormonal imbalances I'm
going through a lot of challenges every
day and so it's not an easy decision by
any means and but for me I felt that it
was um my only choice because I didn't
want to live my life wondering every day
if that little nickel was ovarian cancer
and seeing my grandma go through it was
I think enough for me to not I don't
want to go through it or Michelle Heaton
we really appreciate your time and
sharing your story with us thanks very
much indeed
no thank you for having me thank you